[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul I was in bed but then
this thing got announced and I had to
come down and make a video Deadpool 3 is
happening Hugh Jackman is returning to
the role of Wolverine and you know we've
got those puns on point like them claws
you know what I'm just gonna skip all
the crap we're gonna get into the teaser
hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now
I've had to really search my soul on
this one his first appearance in the MCU
obviously needs to feel special we need
to stay true to the character find new
depth and motivation new meaning every
Deadpool needs to stand out and stand
apart
it's been an incredible challenge that
has forced me to reach down deep inside
and I
[Music]
yeah it's just completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah very short but sweet but
completely blew my mind when I saw this
and just to see Hugh Jackman walking
around in the background and agreeing to
be Wolverine God damn I am so hyped Hugh
Jackman is Wolverine and the MCU is
something I wanted to see for so long
and every time they brought a potential
casting rumors for the character I've
just thought you know what the guy did
such a good job I don't really want to
see anyone else in the role so I'm so
hyped that they managed to get him back
I think Deadpool 3 is gonna be amazing
and yeah what an announcement this is
you know what every week I'm like maybe
Marvel's falling off you know they they
haven't had a big massive thing for a
while and yeah and just to see this I'm
sure you can hear it in my voice I'm
absolutely over the moon not that much
to break down and we know very little at
this point but I've been saying for
years that Deadpool 3 is in development
um I have had sources close to Marvel
I've talked about it I've done a number
of videos on it the pandemic did push
things back and but huge Jack recommend
I mean he's just been someone that I
never thought would come back Logan was
such a banger a complete classic one of
the best comic book movies of all time
and I always thought that he was gonna
take that as his final film and just bow
out after that however this is
completely amazing and it's blown me
away getting this announcement I think
that going forward yeah the MCU they're
really you know what they they have
their stumbles they have their folds but
when they announce things like this it's
difficult to not get swept up in it now
going forward I am hoping that Hugh
Jackman continues playing the part for
the foreseeable future the guy is
amazing I think he's a brilliant actor
he's he's definitely got a lot of talent
you you know that he can do musicals he
can do anything and I think he's going
to lend himself really well to Deadpool
because he's such a comedic character
and to have Ryan Reynolds to bounce off
of I think it's going to be something
really special I am very hyped this
thing has just been announced so there's
not an um there's not a massive amount
of details that are here but you know
this is worth getting out of bed for
definitely and going forward we've got
announcements like Secret Wars that are
pulling different characters from the
MCU and the Multiverse together I think
Hugh Jackman would fit perfectly into
that we've obviously already had
Professor Rex showing up in the
Multiverse of Madness and there's just
so many things that they can do and if
X-Men are in the MCU now which I think
mutants are because apparently Neymar's
one then yeah just get get them all back
you know get Evan Peters back as wrath
but I mean Quicksilver get him back as
that and yeah I think the fans are going
to be in for something really really
special here so yeah that's that's the
announcement absolutely Blown Away by it
it's uh you know I'm so glad I checked
my phone
um and got up out of bed to do this I'm
just very very excited you know I
remember going to see the first X-Men
movie with my mother
um all the way back in the the early
noughties and that was something that
really just reignited my love for comic
book films Hugh Jackman was obviously
the star of that he did such an
outstanding role in that movie and he
you know he he helped shape the next
decade or the next two decades at least
of of comic book movies
um and his performance has just been
something that I've constantly gone back
to and thought this was perfect casting
you know I I know it wasn't like the
comic book so maybe it's not perfect
casting but to take the character in the
direction that he did and the Catapult
himself to being a mega star it was
absolutely amazing and I'm so happy he's
returned might be the only time he does
it but for me I'm hoping that he comes
back with things like Secret Wars and
yeah absolutely buzzing with this
announcement and I hope that you guys
are as hype design if if you're over the
age of 30
um like me then you know and you love
comic book movies I'm sure you will be
if you're under the age of 30 you
probably are as well it's a really big
deal um and shout out to Ryan Reynolds
for locking this down
the guy's clearly been pulling out all
the stops to make his MCU debut as big
as possible and this is going to be
something for the history books you know
seeing these two characters on screen
again after
um X-Men Origins Wolverine yeah that's
that's gonna be uh that's gonna be
something special because obviously that
movie you know it wasn't that well
received I had a lot of issues with it
where it leaked um with unfinished VFX
but just the ending battle with them
Deadpool and Wolverine it wasn't it
wasn't good was there I mean let's be
honest it wasn't a good film but uh yeah
this is I'm sure they're gonna poke fun
at it um and this is gonna redeem it all
so very very hyped something that's very
very special very dear to my heart as
well and yeah I I am absolutely out of
the Moon with this the hello just the
logo itself looks incredible and this
totally you know fits in line with
what my dreams of the MCU are you know
when when we hear them TV as we do here
you know different characters that could
be coming across and to get Deadpool uh
in the MC that's obviously a big thing
but to get Hugh Jackman as Wolverine you
guys have completely knocked it out the
park I probably will be back to slagging
off She-Hulk um very soon and just
saying MCU is just going through the
motions but yeah what what a you know
the reaction on Twitter right now is
just people saying they won uh we won
sorry and uh yeah that that is
absolutely crazy
um and even John Krasinski now is is
tweeting stuff like wait is this our
movie so I'm guessing he's being
announced as the Reed Richards
officially soon
um but yeah what a massive get and this
is uh this is gonna be something really
special so thanks for sitting with me as
I I just ramble through things play the
clips several times and uh yeah I hope I
hope you're as hyped as I am obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts so make
sure you comment below and let me know
and also we are running competition
right now giving away three copies of
dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and comment below with
your thoughts on the news if you want
something else to watch we've got a Last
of Us trailer breakdown which will be
linked on screen right now and lots and
lots of fun with that lots of things to
point out and yeah I'm still buzzing
over this so definitely go ahead over
there right after this and with out of
the way I've been poor you've been the
best and you've been the best as well
riding you you take care yourself I'll
see you soon take care peace